do you believe in visualization
yes how does it work
well it works however you want it to
work but i think that
so i'm really fascinated by the science
behind it
i just think it's so fascinating and so
dr joe dispenza
teaches a lot of the science behind it
i'm so fascinated so
he talks about he gave this really good
example of
a an experiment that they did i don't
know if he conducted or someone else did
a long time ago
where they monitored the brain of
somebody rehearsing practicing the piano
and it was for a certain amount of hours
a couple days a week or something and
they
literally would get brain scans or
you know i don't know the scientific
term but they studied their brain
um to see what happens like what part of
the brain lights up
you know what happens in your brain when
you're rehearsing playing the piano
and then they did the same thing but
asked him to just rehearse it in his
mind
just visualize yourself rehearsing for
the same amount of time so if it was
three hours
spend three hours rehearsing playing the
piano not actually touching a piano
and what they found was the exact same
part of the brain lit up
and what this was really showing them is
that your brain doesn't really know the
difference between something imagined or
visualized
and something real that's right in front
of you and they talk about
when you visualize what you want
happening and you you close your eyes
and you really see it
in detail and you play it out like a
movie in your mind
you're actually impacting the quantum
field i mean this is like
quantum physics and it's getting a
little sciencey but you're actually like
impacting the quantum field around you
and it creates
possibility like it create like now now
that you envisioned it it
exists in real life somewhere and he
talks about
he does a much better job explaining
because i'm an art brain not a science
brain
and so i kind of summarized the science
that he shared but
the way that i remember it but he said
that you know for example in the morning
when you wake up
if you have a thought i have to go to
the bathroom right when you wake up
and then your body goes to the bathroom
so your body physically follows the
thought
so when you visualize you know play out
this movie in your mind of you
booking a project or you know getting
anything that you want
your body then will follow the thought
and it will lead you to
actions and things to do and you know
connections people
to talk to whatever um to to follow that
thought because your brain thinks it's
real doesn't know the difference
and and joe talks about dr joe talks
about um and i don't really do this
enough i'm a very visual person
so it's super easy for me to visualize
and i can kind of do it without even
having to go into a deep meditation like
i can just
i can connect to it so easily because
i'm such a visual person
but dr joe talks about like for this to
work really well
it's best if you can do this in a
meditative state so if you can just
close your eyes
and visualize whatever it is that you
want to visualize let's say
like i do this great meditation
visualization with my clients where like
i might walk them through a day of them
going to set
you know booking you know on a project
that they love you know
they get up and they get in their car
and we play out the whole day you drive
to paramount studios you get to your
trailer you
sit in the hair and make you know
literally all the details of it and like
what's around you and
um dr joe talks about like incorporating
your five senses
you know you know sense of like how does
it smell you know
what are you touching what do you so to
really um
you know make it come to life in your
mind and so he says
that if you can get to a place in your
meditative state
and every time i talk about this i'm
like erica you need to do this more
because this is so great
if you can get to a place in your
meditative state where you're
visualizing
and you forget about you're no longer
connected to time
your body or your environment meaning
you're just so into this visualization
that you have no idea five minutes past
or 30 minutes past
right so you're not like super aware of
time you
are not fidgeting you know or touching
your body so like you're
just so into it that you're not even
aware of your body or itchy or you know
whatever we do when we're
wiggling in a in a meditation and then
your environment
like you're not thinking about the room
that you're sitting in
when you can get to a place where you're
not no longer aware of those three
things
that's like the magic space where the
visualization comes to life and really
kind of creates in this
quantum field so i think visualization
is just
such an amazing tool for us to use like
one it just gets you excited you know i
think it's just good to help get you in
the energy
which i can even do just talking about
the specifics of my dream i get excited
you know
if anyone asks me about like the house i
want to buy i will go on forever
and i get so excited and i can tell you
all the details that's like
brings me that energy of the
visualization um
but so i think it's good for that sense
and like it gets you excited and it gets
you connected to the possibility which
then will lead
to ideas or actions or bigger risks you
know
any of the things that good energy will
lead to um and then also you're
from a scientific perspective you know
you're essentially creating
this possibility in the quantum field
and now
you're expecting it to happen and so
you're doing all the things you would do
if you knew it was coming
do you have any examples of how this
creative visualization has helped
some of your clients so one of the
things that i have my clients do in
addition to
visualizing is to write it out and so
i have what they do we call it a clear
intentions list
and so they write like a list of what
their intentions are what they want to
create
and so i mean this happens all the time
they get the agent or manager
that matches everything on their list
you know they create things all the time
and one of my clients actually the other
day had posted in the facebook group
that
she recently got a new agent that
feels really great it's a great
relationship they're bringing her
high quality auditions they they
understand each other it seems like they
really support her dream you know like
all these dreamy things that people want
from
a rep that they often don't get
and she said i i because i told her i'm
like man i wish we could go back to your
two-year
ago self and tell that version of you
like that you got this great rep and
you're having this wonderful experience
and she's like i know
she said like i remember one of your
other clients
having it happen to her a year ago and
feeling like so excited for her and
seeing that it was possible and really
wanting that for myself
and and then it happened for her so um
so not so it's not necessarily that
they're going through the whole like
meditation
visualization although i think a lot of
my clients are doing that naturally
um but really visualizing in any kind of
sense
even outside of meditation what it is
they want and then having it happen
do you ever see people who are unable to
make positive changes in their life
yeah yeah i do
i think you know no judgment again i
think everyone's on their own
path and actually this is something that
i had to work on as a coach
to not take that on
for myself and beat myself up about it
like i didn't do a good enough job i
didn't
i you know i couldn't i couldn't change
them i you know my work couldn't
um help them change you know i've
struggled with that
in the past um and really had to learn
like
i give them the tools but it's up to
them what they do with it you know i
can't make anybody do
anything so um
i've definitely seen that happen but i
do think that everyone's on their own
path and i think that people come around
when they
when they come around and when they when
they need to when it's right for them
um you know tony robbins talks about
how everyone moves towards pain or
pleasure so
a lot of times he says you know people
don't change until the pain becomes too
great
and that's been my experience 100 as
well you know it's like
like i remember when i was working on a
show full-time and starting my coaching
business
and i really got to the point where i
needed
to leave the show in order for my
business to take off if that's what i
wanted like there was only so much i
could do
with my business working on a tv show
full time especially tv hours you know
working 8 10 hour day or
10 12 hour days um
i knew i had to leave the job
but it took me a while to make that you
know to actually make that leap you know
as ambitious and driven as i am i have
my own moments of resistance
and i it took me time and it wasn't
until the pain became too great where i
said
what am i doing i can't stay here like i
have to get out you know something
happened at work it wasn't even a big
thing but it was
something that gave me reason to leave
and
it wasn't until the pain became too
great that i actually made the change
um and so yeah so tony says that we're
moving towards
pain or towards pleasure where like
there's something you want
and so you make a decision based on that
because you really want it
so i think that um
when people you know aren't aren't
making positive changes in their life
maybe the pain just hasn't become too
great yet you know and maybe that moment
will happen for them in the future
you